vous pensez qu'il est mieux qu'il
continue de se cacher
que les prêtres se fâche
est-ce que vous êtes pour le mariage des
prêtres entre eux
c'est la seule façon net d'emmener
quelqu'un à l'hôtel
en France les gens dans la rue
[Musique]
je comprends pas
je vois je vois pas pourquoi ils peuvent
l'être les Juifs le sont les protestants
le son je vois pas pourquoi qu'on
priverait un homme du désir d'aimer de
la chair et autre chose qui peuvent
approfondir le désir de vivre à deux et
en communion quoi donc vous êtes pour le
mariage des prêtres entre eux
le mariage de prêtres
non alors là non
non
vous pensez qu'il est mieux qu'il
continue de se cacher
que les prêtres se fâchent se cachent
cache leur amour
je préfère oui si je connaissais un
prêtre qui ont été un peu plus rapproché
que les autres mais j'avais quoi j'avais
10-12 ans
ouais ouais mais bon c'est
ouais quoi ouais mais non mais c'est
contradict au mariage à cette époque
avec lui
amoureux un peu non
c'était comme un père je sais pas c'est
marrant mais non mon père un petit peu
incestueux type
donc vous êtes pour l'union libre en ce
qui concerne les prêtres
moi je suis pas homosexuel comment
le mariage est prêt entre eux
mon Seigneur
une relation sexuelle avec un prêtre
et les sœurs entre elles
pareil pareil et les curés et les soeurs
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu